one of the big questions about the 2022
midterm elections has been as we get
past the primaries
what do the general elections look like
pennsylvania is a great example in
pennsylvania we had very prominent
primaries uh for the governor's race uh
this guy doug mastriano who is
essentially a a big lie
a january sixth rioter that that's
essentially what he is uh doug mastriano
won the republican primary for governor
in pennsylvania and will now face josh
shapiro but the question is well how is
that race looking uh in the republican
senate race mehmet oz was endorsed by
trump
one ultimately won a very very close
primary but the question is how is oz
faring against john fetterman
the overwhelming victor in the
democratic primary for the pennsylvania
senate what does it look like for
november we finally have those numbers
and it really depends on whether you
want to be a glass half full or glass
half empty sort of person uh when it
comes to these poles whether we say that
it's looking good or that it's not
looking good so let's look at the polls
which we've been waiting for for a long
time the post-gazette reports democrats
john fetterman and josh shapiro lead
republicans memit oz and doug mastriano
in the first big pennsylvania general
election poll okay that's good the
democrats are winning for uh the general
election well but how much well
this is where it's maybe not quite so
good
in the senate contest
democratic candidate john fetterman
pennsylvania sitting lieutenant governor
is up by nine over republican member oz
the celebrity cardio thoracic surgeon
that's 46 to 37 with 13 of respondents
undecided okay that's the senate race in
the race for governor democrat josh
shapiro the state attorney general leads
republican doug mastriano a state
senator by a slimmer margin by 4 44 to
40 with 13 percent of respondents again
declaring themselves undecided okay so
we have the numbers are these numbers
good or are these numbers bad i can
genuinely make two completely different
cases to you about this let me make to
you
the most optimistic case
the republican primaries got way more
attention than the democratic primaries
josh shapiro was unopposed john
fetterman was expected to easily win and
he did despite all of the attention on
the republican primaries the democrats
are still winning
josh shapiro is arguably much less well
known than doug mastriano he didn't have
any kind of like major endorsement that
i'm aware of like masteriano had trumps
and despite all of that all of that
attention all of the name recognition
the democrats are still winning and
they're winning both races great okay
but wow david sir thank you for the
optimistic case
now what's the pessimistic case well the
pessimistic case
is uh fetterman is winning by nine but
there's 13 percent undecided and
pennsylvania is although it has
typically typically leaned blue to the
left
um it doesn't always and 13 undecided is
not particularly good and 9 is not a
comfortable lead there and then when you
look at the gubernatorial race you can
make an even more pessimistic case which
is wait a second
despite the fact that masteriano
is
quite literally a rioter in the sense
that he allegedly uh
passed and breached police barricades in
dc on january 6. despite that he's only
losing by four
with 13 undecided that's a disaster
because the general campaigns are only
just starting this is really not good
now which of the two
cases do i lean towards i lean slightly
to the pessimistic case we have a
situation in the united states right now
where mastriano was a participant at the
insurrection he spent over three
thousand dollars to bus over a hundred
trump supporters to dc on january six he
was seen crossing police barricades uh
despite denying it and even despite all
of that
he's only losing by four and thirteen
percent are still undecided because we
are in an era where these things are no
longer disqualifying think of the
hollywood accent the access hollywood
tape with donald trump in the past that
would have ended many elected officials
or potential elected officials careers
and trump went on to become president of
the united states and almost to get
himself re-elected so
is it better that the two democrats in
pennsylvania are winning rather than
losing of course it's better if they
were losing it would be an even bigger
disaster but these leads particularly
the masteriano lead the master the josh
shapiro lead over masteriano rather
these are not comfortable leads in any
sense so when we think about where is
there a race that we can really kind of
make a difference and we've talked about
this whole marcus flowers versus
marjorie taylor green thing marcus
flowers is a fine candidate against
marjory taylor green and georgia but as
many people have written in
it's not really likely that being such a
red district pouring money in for marcus
flowers or phone banking is going to
remove marjorie taylor green and i i
never say give up on a race but it is
statistically true that that's a big
uphill battle
if efforts were concentrated on the
really important races this one in
pennsylvania could be huge because
number one fetterman versus oz could
decide who controls the senate for the
next two years and the governor of
pennsylvania
could decide who wins pennsylvania
uh in 2024 the real winner or whoever
doug mastriano wants to see these are
really consequential races does it not
make more sense to put our efforts there
it's a question that we're going to have
to figure out as we get closer to
november
and then into 2024 let me know what you
think find me on twitter at dpakman but
at least they're not losing that's what
we can say so far
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night improves sleep
in many ways our sponsor chilly sleep
creates systems that cool down your bed
promoting deeper higher quality sleep it
also just feels great i use it at home
i'd recommend it to anyone and i've
recommended it to some friends who now
use it as well
chile sleeps product the uhler the cube
and the doc pro
they're all water-based temperature
controlled pads that fit onto your
existing mattress you can keep your bed
as low as 55 degrees as hot as 115
degrees i like 60 their new doc pro
sleep system has double the cooling
power of other models five times the
cooling contact whisper quiet you can
control it with your phone it's awesome
with chilly sleep there's no more
feeling hot at night no more sweating
cooling your bed down like this is
amazing you really have to try it for
yourself when you go to chilisleep.com
pacman you'll get thirty percent off of
the uhler and cube sleep systems and ten
percent off the new doc pro this offer
is only for my audience the link is down
below